as the biden white house implodes poor
joe biden he's lashing out today he
called our own peter ducey a quote
stupid
son of a [ __ ]
now it's angry joe biden once promised
to restore civility telling his
appointees he would fire them on the
spot if they disrespected others of
course the rules they don't apply to joe
and his comments about peter ducey are
especially ridiculous given that biden's
own weakened mental abilities in a
moment we're going to play the tape and
peter ducey will respond also we're just
learning at this second
that
biden apparently called peter ducey uh
just a short time ago and we'll find out
how that went all right but first
tonight major cities all around the
country they are now reeling from
another weekend of violence in new york
city a career criminal
viciously targeting two nypd officers
killing one critically injuring another
officer jason rivera was only 22 years
old officer wilbert mora he was only 27
years old he's fighting for his life
tonight and according to reports the
deranged killer quote kept firing at the
wounded cops even as they lay helplessly
on the floor a complete execution now
sadly as we speak cops all across the
country they're being targeted at an
alarming rate according to the fbi while
intentional police killings have now
reached a 20-year high
346 officers were shot in the line of
duty in 2021 alone another multi-year
high meanwhile ambush style attacks
against cops that was up a whopping 115
percent over the previous year and it's
not just new york on sunday morning in
washington d.c an officer was rushed to
the hospital after getting shot on the
same day in houston texas corporal
charles charles galloway was murdered
during a quote routine traffic stop
there's no such thing in city after city
violent crime is spiraling out of
control carjackings look at this they're
up by a whopping 510 percent now
downtown shootings in chicago wow you
think it can't get higher they're
already up a whopping 220 percent
california just recorded the most
murders in 20 years in 2021 at least 12
u.s cities set a new record for murder
why is it happening well if you listen
to the democrats and propagandist
gensake
guns are just magically floating through
the air by themselves the guns are the
problem
the guns hijack carjacking the cars
anyway they're terrorizing the
communities they say all across the
country the reality is this
defund dismantle no bail is all
responsible for this major wave of
violence in city after city police
budgets have been slashed including a
billion dollar
cut into the new york police department
now to make matters worse you've got far
left prosecutors they're stopped
prosecuting crimes in the name of
equality and equity you have some
jurisdictions now even eliminating bail
for many crimes and turning jails into
revolving doors and our streets into a
violent free-for-all terrified by his
radical base joe biden is doing nothing
to reduce crime by the way in many
states now you can just steal as long as
you don't steal up to a thousand dollars
950 bucks you're only going to get a
ticket during the 2020 summer of
violence joe biden all but ignored all
of the carnage we had dozens of
americans dead thousands of cops injured
billions of property damage arson
looting kamala harris actually promoted
the bail fund to get violent criminals
out of jail she praised the lapd police
cuts you know protecting the peaceful
law-abiding americans why don't we
protect them this administration is
providing cover for criminals all while
supporting groups like the group black
lives matter you know recently they
complained that murdered police officers
are treated like heroes in tear jerker
press conferences uh the group black
lives matter apparently prefers oh
that's right what do we want dead cops
when we want them now pigs in a blanket
fry them like bacon or so they say but
today when pressed by our own peter
ducey a rare moment of truth
peter had a battle with jen saki who
admitted that an underfunding of police
departments has led to a surge in crime
take a look
would you agree that the most important
job for any president is to keep
americans safe
i would agree
so he said that the president's never
satisfied if people don't feel safe does
he know that after a year in office
people do not feel safe in this country
well peter i think if we look at the
facts here we've seen a surge of crime
over the last two years would you agree
with that
so what are you attributing the rising
crime to then well i think we should be
responsible in how reporting to the
public what the what the what the uh
roles are what the reasons for the surge
in crime gun violence is a huge reason
for the surge in crime
uh under funding of pulse and police
departments and their need for
additional resources something the
president has advocated for consistently
through the course of his career that's
something we know we need to take action
on
hey jen just like kovades went up in
2021 under joe biden well the same thing
with violent crime we just gave you the
numbers for 2021
in case you weren't paying attention it
was joe biden that said oh yeah i'd
reallocate funds away from the police it
was kamala harris that said oh yeah
praise the lapd for cutting their budget
anyway biden took a slightly different
tone today didn't want to answer any
questions and he called our own peter
ducey a stupid son of a [ __ ] really
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
stupid son of a [ __ ] mr unity strikes
again in all seriousness joe biden
really shouldn't be casting stones from
an extremely extremely fragile glass
house hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else